- (singing) Chicken time!
(upbeat music)
- I don't eat fast food that much
but if I do I just go all in.
- I don't think that I'm boujis
about my chicken sandwiches though.
- Well, this looks disgusting.
- It looks like a slice of cheese.
- I don't know what's up
with this whole gloss.
- Mmm.
This is why people eat this stuff.
- It's a little gooey, the bread.
I don't really like the bread.
- I like it, I like the
quality of the chicken.
- The chicken is nicely spiced.
- This tastes like what chicken
is supposed to taste like.
- This is the best bun by far.
- Mmm, it's a nice bun.
- It's the Kim Kardashian of buns.
- Not as good.
This doesn't have any of the crispiness
that this one had.
- This is like plastic toy food.
- This one's more clumpy.
There's like pieces of chicken inside it.
- This is like if you cooked
chicken in an Easy Bake Oven.
- Ooh, this is thicker.
- This is nice.
- The bread actually looks like bread
so that's like a huge improvement.
- Mmm.
- This has gotta be my favorite so far.
- Mine too.
- I think all of them are Burger King
and this has been a
psychological experiment.
- This chicken is sweating.
- Yeah, this is definitely
maybe the thickest
slice of chicken that we've had.
- This chicken makes
me think of McDonald's.
- And you know what it's missing?
That delicious McDonald's ketchup.
- That first one is just crushing it.
I'm upset that we started here.
- Mm-hmm.
- Jesus, look at that, that
is substantial chicken.
That's what I'm talking about.
- Chick-fil-A, it's delicious.
- God damn it, why you
gotta be homophobic?
(singing) I got a pickle
that makes you go like this.
Heyyy.
(singing) I got a pickle in
my sandwich and it's good.
- I don't love it, again,
this would be better
as spicy chicken.
- By default, I guess
this is one of these.
- Child, this is rubber.
- This is a bad one.
- Ugh.
(gagging)
- This is good, this is the best one.
- It tastes like the shit that you get
from the frozen section.
- That is tasty.
Come on, are you kidding me?
- That was a chicken's butt.
- I love this.
- What was the best one?
- Tie.
- Definitely this one.
- This one.
- Jack in the Box, great work.
Chick-fil-A, you know what your'e doing.
- I might reconsider my
stance on Jack in the Box.
- Yeah, seriously.
- I would consider going there now.
(bell ringing)
- I feel like I can't chew any more
because I got like seven
breads in my mouth.